Speaker 1: Stephen Bannon had an epic meltdown
over Trump's NFT trading card grift. You have to
see this video. There are elements in MAGA world
that are furious about this nft launch last week.
Trump teasing. I'm going to be making a major
announcement tomorrow. And the announcement was
that you could buy digital trading cards
of scrums in various outfits looking like
a superhero. They should have had Trump on the
toilet at 3 a.m. posting to Truth Social Growth.
Speaker 2: Central.
Speaker 1: Or Trump on The
View saying If Ivanka weren't my daughter, I would
like to date her. Those would be the interesting
Trump trading cards. Instead, they were like
Trump in a Spider-Man outfit. Okay. Anyway,
Steve Bannon can't believe it.
Steve Bannon melts down and says,
What? On who came up with this disastrous idea.
Speaker 2: Now they're called Trump Digital
Trading Cards. Okay, these cards feature some
of the I can't do this anymore. He's one of
the greatest presidents in history. But I got to
tell you, that's not true. Who ever what business
partner enabling the comms team in anybody
Mar-A-Lago. And I love the folks down there. But
we're at war. They ought to be fired today. Right.
He came out with something that's so important.
Speaker 1: Which I still.
Speaker 2: Don't think gives
to the. Part of it. And hey, you don't have
three harder cores than Cortez, Bannon and
Sub Gordon right there. And we're getting.
Speaker 1: Blown up all. We're the biggest
supporters. And this is stupid.
Speaker 2: They on this sub
walked me through it. Walk me through
your assessment of this, sir. Yeah.
Never should have happened. I mean, look, it's
fine. It's hyperbolic, but whoever wrote that,
that pitch should be fired and should never
be involved in any. I don't want them making.
Speaker 1: Trump should be fired and
never be involved in politics ever again.
Speaker 2: The presidential napkins from Mar a
Lago. Okay. Anybody who came up with that and the
president's war chest is pretty strong right now.
Speaker 1: Yes. Because he claimed he was raising
money for 2022 candidates and he kept 80% of it.
Speaker 2: We've got two years until the actual,
you know, inauguration. We don't have time to
waste. If you want to do this kind of stuff,
you know, have have a pee on, do it. Okay,
get get somebody who's recognized in the
MAGA world to, you know, put that
face to this thing and do it. Yeah.
Speaker 1: Like Sepp Gorka or Steve Bannon.
Speaker 2: Right. But the president should
not be involved with this when we.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So this was, you know,
MAGA world was pretty split over the stupid
digital trading cards. Some of them maybe
they really liked it, but at least they went along
with it and said, this is amazing. But Bannon and
Gorka couldn't do it. Now there's a lot of money
laundering questions around that. The idea would
be that you could launder money through these NFT
trading cards. Someone could potentially buy a
whole bunch of these digital trading cards using
illicit funds or funds that they would like to
really be contributing to Trump's campaign. But
they're in excess of the legal limits for those
contributions. They could buy a bunch of those
cards, and that would be a way to funnel money
to Donald Trump. You could also launder money
personally by buying a bunch of these cards
with illicit funds, then at a later date selling
them. And then it potentially might be a way to
clean that money for the individual. A couple
of different ways that you could actually use
this to launder, but a absolutely pathetic and
humiliating decision which financially may have
actually worked out because they're claiming that
the trading cards sold out. I know it's just all
completely bonkers, but they're claiming that the
grift work that they got $99 out of enough people,
MAGA people, and I'm not going
to redo it. But remember,
cult members are overwhelmingly likely to
continue falling for this stuff. The cult leader
says people who get scammed are overwhelmingly
likely to be scammed again and again and again.
We've spoken about why extensively won't redo
that here, but it seems to be happening. Make
sure you're following The David Pakman Show on
Instagram at David Pakman show. If you would
like to see an incredible, heartwarming picture
of me with my daughter taking in the Argentinean
men's National Team World Cup win yesterday, check
out my personal Instagram at David Pakman. It is
it is a picture that will bring a tear to your
eye. Her first World Cup. And we got the win.
It's incredible. We'll take a quick break.
I know many of you have said, David, sir,
you've got to cover America fast. Oh, believe me,
we're going to get to America Fest after the break